all right ladies and gentlemen here
again with your
mobile locksmith from urban lock and key
today we're doing
a four button remote
key for a 2010 honda accord sedan
make sure your specific sedan and coop
remotes do not work universal
so at this moment we're going to be
doing the onboard programming for the
remote first
always confirm the remote works
sometimes the remotes program with the
keep
being programmed other times you have to
do the remote programming first
then to keep programming let's get
started
what you're going to do is you're going
to start by being in the vehicle
driver side door closed all doors closed
you're going to take the working
functional key
insert it into the ignition you're going
to go
all the way to the on position
you're gonna push either the lock or
unlock button
go to the off position back to the on
position
block unlock button again off position
on position lock unlock button again
off position on position you hurt the
lock cycle
you're gonna hit lock or unlock on every
remote that's being programmed
that's it
[Music]